regen sich ja schon länger darüber
haufen haben heute auch eine spannende
these mitgebracht dass die politiker
eher die angepassten belohnen genau das
so sehe ich das ich habe das
ausdrücklich so gewählt weil ich finde
wir müssen also fast alle menschen
wissen irgendwie was kanzel culture ist
weil er gab es ein paar top profilierte
fälle dass in der veranstaltung mit lisa
eckert in hamburg abgesagt wurde weil da
die antifa drohte zu randalieren das als
bernd lucke aus dem eu-parlament
zurückkamen und da wieder seine vwl
vorlesung halten wollte dass die von der
hundertschaft beschützt werden mussten
weil die leute ihn als [ __ ]
niedergeschrieben haben ihn angegriffen
haben körperlich sogar mit
trillerpfeifen im hörsaal das weiß jeder
weil die medien darüber berichten ich
habe jetzt absichtlich so ein bisschen
möchte ich davon abstrahieren und sagen
es gibt ja die meisten menschen sind
nicht bei der antifa die meisten
menschen sind nicht bei irgendeiner
linksradikalen aktivisten gruppe aber
was leben eigentlich unsere politischen
eliten vor wie schätzen die eigentlich
die meinungsfreiheit und da haben wir so
unsägliche sachen wie das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz 2017 was zu einem
irren overclocking geführt hat also dass
sachliche kritik an an die scheuer
oder sachliche islamkritik alles vom
grundgesetz gedeckt das teilen eines
heinrich heine zitates in der korona
krise wo er irgendwie gesagt hat der
deutsche ist zum untertan geboren der
erfolgt jede autorität das wurde
hunderte male jetzt gelöscht in der
korona krise als hate speech gegen
deutsche also massenhaftes unsägliches
oper overclocking auch ein gesetz was
von putin sogar kopiert wurde in der
russischen staatsduma wir haben so
sachen wie auch dass die die
hochschulrektoren in hamburg sich gar
nicht distanziert haben von diesen
extremen störungen dieser lücke
vorlesungen oder wir haben eine frau
merkel die ein un migrations pakt
unterzeichnet hat wo steht die
unterzeichnenden parteien also die
nationalstaaten verpflichten sich auf
ein klima in den medien hinzuwirken wo
zuwanderung als bereicherung dargestellt
wird da frage ich mich als
liberaldemokratischer mensch wohl ewig
denn hier in china oder was was soll
denn das ja also ein paar leute haben es
nicht unterschrieben sebastian kurz der
böse
aus österreich zum beispiel nicht unter
anderem aus diesem grund und da frage
ich mich mir geht es gar nicht mehr ich
habe in meinem buch habe ich viel über
die antifa über also links aktivistische
identitäts politische gruppen aber mir
kommt immer mehr der gedanke so
eigentlich leben die januar in
extremform das aus was auch ein paar
stufen höher von leuten die jetzt nicht
ganz radikale aktivisten sind vorgelebt
wird also meinungsfreiheit ist
gefährlich das folgt der große lümmel
auch heinrich heine das darf bloß nicht
die falschen meinungen hören des modells
großflächen einer ganz klassisch franken
haben sie das gefühl dass sie nicht ihre
meinung sagen dürfen man kann sehr
vieles wir haben eine folgenreiche wir
gesagt wir könnten ja alles sei also
könnte ich das glaube ich sagen was sie
wollen das heißt die meinungsfreiheit
und setze ich mein bild ist die größte
medienmarke des landes und ich sagte
ihnen sie können jetzt alle sagen also
hab ich auch die meinungsfreiheit bei
der grenze deutscher immer um eine
bestrafung die keine diskursive
auseinandersetzung ist also nicht einer
sagt oder herr zitat ist hat ein essay
geschrieben geschrieben der redet
kompletten schluss jetzt widersprechen
sondern es geht darum der herzen gar das
muss ein auftrag verlieren der könnte
aus einer organisation ausgeschlossen
werden eine generelle reisen da habe ich
extrem viel protokolliert gibt es viele
aus dem angloamerikanischen raum aber
eben auch viele hier das canvas absurdes
sein wie ein paar gute sind jetzt nicht
leute mit denen ich mich jetzt besonders
identifiziere aber die haben in
schleswig-holstein vor dem rathaus in
der kreisstadt immer mikrofon aufgebaut
also weil deren tochter ist im
unterricht collagiert im sommer mit den
masken tragen wie gesagt wir stellen
jetzt ein mikro auf da kann jeder mal
zur politik seine meinung sagen und die
das sind so theaterpädagoge war sie die
sollten preiskriegen für so ein
theaterprojekt zu nachhaltiger regionale
ernährung und das wurde monate lang
aufgeschoben weil da die linkspartei und
noch ein paar andere gesagt hat das sind
ja vielleicht querdenker weil sie da
dieses mikrofon also die vertreten auch
sachen die ich nicht teile zur ukraine
und zu diesen wellen abgehalten in einer
heute dass alle sagen lassen es ist eine
bestrafung und es hat nichts keine
inhaltliche oder dann kann er sagen
dieses ehepaar vertritt zum corona
völligen quatsch aber sie wollen ja
bestraft indem man ihn einen preis in
höhe von 10.000 euro für ihr
nachhaltigkeitsprojekte
halten sollte und das geht nicht dass
eben doch keine dieser fragen haben sie
denn das gefühl sie können nicht mehr
alle schreiben oder wird man
sanktioniert wenn man eine andere
meinung hat man wird schon sanktioniert
je nachdem was ich unter sanktionen
verstehen sie können liebesentzug es ist
freundin von mir passieren der eigenen
familie leben sie kriegen etwas seltsame
blicke mir macht das eigentlich nichts
aus im gegenteil ich finde das
eigentlich sehr lustig ich stehe morgens
auf und schon haben wir fünf leute ein
magengeschwür ich liebe es nicht von ja
und das ist in der tat so dass
entschuldigt die einfachen leute mit
denen ich viel umgang haben schon das
gefühl haben sie können nicht sagen was
sie denken weil es im betrieb am
arbeitsplatz im verein von den anderen
nicht gern gehört und gesehen verwehrt
hatte jemand auflegen dinge schritt wir
kriegen ja auch viel zu schauen was es
freut mich mal sehr an dann habe ich den
bild artikeln gepostet gehabt mit dem
krank durch impfungen und dann hat
jemand geschrieben auf lincoln er würde
das gerne leiten aber sein arbeitgeber
über polieren auch was man so auf social
media neigt da habe ich dann erst mal
gedacht zu den arbeitgeber würde ich gar
nicht arbeiten wollen aber man muss ja
auch ehrlich sagen manche sind lange im
betrieb wollen die sicherheit aufgeben
da darf man auch nicht wissen sagen ganz
lange leute sind damit beschäftigt ihr
leben täglich zu organisieren wir haben
nicht die kraft und die zeit für solche
auseinandersetzungen das hat das ist
mein hobby die anderen müssen um 7 auf
stehen die kinder zur kita bringen und
dann müssen sie gucken dass sie bei aldi
die sonderangebote erwischen da sieht es
ganz anders aus wir haben aber noch
etwas anderes wir haben in deutschland
inzwischen die meinung durchgesetzt dass
meinungsfreiheit ein prima gut ist aber
nur für richtige meinung nicht dass
meinungsfreiheit gerade falsche
meinungen schützt und im übrigen gibt es
grenzen auch der meinungsfreiheit völlig
zurecht man kann jemand verleugnen
verneint man kann man sagen du bist ein
kinderschänder du hast deine frau
umgebracht es gibt grenzen und die
grenzen sollen auch ein gehalt das
richtig so sehe ich habe das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz war ein totalitäres
instrument das auch noch nicht mal
funktioniert hat dass man das schaffen
und es gibt auch auflösungserscheinungen
im rechtsstaat überhaupt ich finde es
absolut unsäglich dass irgendwelche
hysterischen kinder am platz der
festkleben
tausende von leuten schlecken ihren
autos falls bei der hitze produzieren
unglaublich viel stickstoff und dann
kommen die bezirksbürgermeisterin
solidarisiert sich mit diesen kindern
ich bitte sie welche einfache bürger
davor respekt vor der staatlichen
autorität als variante hingegen die
cancelled ich finde das problem müsste
man eigentlich nicht nur da ansiedeln
das sozusagen die einfachen leute gehen
zu aldi und kann ihre mahnung ich sage
ich finde das ist schon auch in der
politik oft erfahre ich habe es ja noch
mal selber erzählt ich bin nun irgendwie
relativ selbstbewusst erzogen worden ich
kann mich da auch bestens durchsetzen
aber ich sehe viele menschen die erst
mal 100 filter durchlaufen bevor sie
überhaupt irgendwas sagen weil immer
alles so fremd ist das muss man ihnen
sagen das muss man denn das muss man so
man sonst wenn man eine frauenfeindlich
wenn man was ich gegen subventionen ist
ist man ebenfalls sozial fertig und der
nunmehr und wenn das immer alles glatt
und sachsen etikett kriegt dann trauen
sich die meisten leute oder sie sind
auch einfach zu müde und sagen okay dann
eben halt nicht und was dann auf der
strecke bleibt finde ich da haben sie ja
völlig recht ist immer an so eine
streitkultur dass wir und unsere jedoch
auch gerade hier so richtig schön sagen
ließe sich aber anders muss noch sein
sowas da muss ich doch nicht dass sie
morgen für müssen wirklich wenn sie mal
wenn schon erreicht habe aber ich mag
sie alle für mich ganz ernst es muss
doch in unserem land möglich sein dass
die leute sich mal wieder einfach
richtig fetzen und dann hinterher tut
mir leid oder es war nicht so gemeint
oder wahrheit doch so gemeint also aber
nicht die ganze zeit über dieses
langweilige reden das ist so langweilig
sein können für den nach acht nicht
besser beenden als mit diesem plädoyer
sie zu hause können das ja auch mal
ausprobieren mehr streit mehr über
politik manchmal ist es mühsam und oft
mache es freude und